now I I want to end up in this nice
place which is to say something
you know this work you've done minor
threats which is in bookstores and it's
it's it's available Nationwide yeah like
you have I know that you have these
passions for for comics and you get to
do that you get to be in that world you
get to make this stuff that you used to
stand in line hoping to meet someone
like you well I used to I stood in line
for three hours to meet Neil Gaiman back
in 1993 in San Francisco to get my
season of Mists hardcover signed and now
I'm Matthew The Raven in the Sandman
Show on Netflix that's insane so that
kind of I I always um I remember this
quote from John John Waters is a great
person to pattern your life after
because he's like I work hard at my
stuff so that I don't have to work with
people I don't want to work with and I
can just do the stuff that I like and it
also gives me because a lot of the stuff
that I like to do is not going to make
me any money it's not gonna increase my
fame but it's really interesting so
doing minor threats no writing Comics
does not make you a lot of money but
it's a blast it's so fun to do you write
the script then you get the rough
pencils then you get the inks and then
you get that I mean the whole process to
me I could do it all day and so I'm
lucky enough that I worked hard enough
as a stand-up and I go and do movies and
I can go do comics in the comics that I
put out now I go with companies like
Dark Horse and and where it's all
Creator owned I own it if something
happens with it it's mine I'm not having
to worry about well this company needs
these things and these things and you
know I have to do stuff
I don't want to do a one for me one for
them within a project I'm doing I'm okay
doing a one for me one for them overall
but to split up your own project doing
that that's that drives me that would
drive me crazy yeah like I have this
great story to tell okay but you got to
put where the the Shazam movie's coming
out you got to put Shazam in there oh
you know so that I never had to do that
right you don't have to compromise also
I'm just happy that I'm not a car guy
I'm not a clothing guy I don't care
about to me a car I don't see the
outside of it as long as it gets me
where I'm going I could care less what
it is so all that money I don't put any
money into that I don't own a house that
uh um George Carlin says I don't own a
house that I I use to scare people with
I love that phrase
nice little house I can live in it's I'm
there's no crazy nut I just keep it very
small and very simple and then you get
to just enjoy everything you like that's
all you got to do I don't have to go
hang out with people I don't want to
hang out with you it's all people I love
occasionally you have to do like a like
a podcast to like sell the comic and
that's a slog but otherwise it's uh hang
out with two you don't want to
see what I'm saying hey Patton uh I
could talk to you for 35 hours I could I
could honestly talk to you and uh way
too long it is a uh just it's just a
happening when you're here it means a
lot to me remember you came I was I
can't I'm sorry that I'm saying this we
were in the Soho House yeah and you came
up you were bringing your uh wife and
daughter to breakfast and I and I had
brought my daughter there because he had
a kids activity today but I was up at
the bar at the Soho house and I was
reading the second volume of the Lyndon
Johnson biography anyone of course
you're reading
Lazy Sunday reading
he's just reading Master of the Senate
which basically you can't fire an a15
through bullets through it exactly yeah
it's that thick yeah they actually there
are many tanks now yeah in the military
that are just covered in Robert
laughs